I have to say rebel Wilson not the only
singer on the couch because I'm Matt
LeBlanc you've sung in quite a few shows
oh yeah yes Joey really early on was in
a musical wasn't he
oh yeah you know he was like right in
the very beginning of the first season
like episode four or something was
called Freud was Jimmy Freud yeah do you
remember any of the songs and for
unfortunately I did
all you want is a dinkle but you envy is
a Shuang a sings with which you can
tinkle and crave this and simply let her
someone in our office is a real kind of
friends he like he knows all the
episodes and he was going ask him about
the song in the casino pretty were in
Vegas there's a song in a casino with a
croupier remember you've got the same
hands other hand this hand is you well
okay I need a guy that Joey
not me be Rory in friends maybe check it
out one day meets a guy in the casino
who has who's his exact hand double and
he thinks he has struck it rich now NASA
is gonna want to talk to us this is this
is big
so I come he comes up with this song and
aqui I think it goes like the other week
casa so this hand is your hand this hand
is my hand no wait that's your head no
that's my
they call cut I was up why that was
asked it was going when he won I look
behind me and there's a bus goes past
with my face on it